previously on another dead man walking
12 jurors unanimously convicted Richard
Glossip of murder this was a one-sided
fight that the government waged against
district Lhasa I'm Ian woods and I'd
like to remind you that what you've been
listening to over the past few weeks is
a true story I just thought I'd say that
because the latest events in the Richard
Glossip story are just bizarre truth
really is stranger than fiction it's
been two weeks since the last podcast I
left you with Richard having been given
a 14-day stay of execution granted by
the Oklahoma Court of Criminal Appeals
it was to allow judges to consider new
evidence in the case
Richard was even talking about the
possibility of a retrial being ordered
I'd returned to London everything that
was happening was largely invisible
lawyers for both the states and the
defendants were filing documents with
the court and the judges were reading
them but there was one major development
for the first time we could see and hear
Justin Sneed talking about the crime he
was refusing to back down from his claim
that Richard Glossip
had asked him to kill Barry Van trees
mr. Glossop cohorts me and pleaded with
me for over three months I'm in the
numerous amounts of money that he was
offering me kept changing I didn't know
what his motivation was other than yeah
he kept begging and pleading me until
the point to it he literally pushed me
over an edge right you feel like his
intention was always to say yes yeah
yeah because even even when he asked me
to leave the motel after Clifford
Everhart and the police put me on a task
of searching the motel he's the one that
ran up to me and begged me to even leave
the motel and going and telling me that
he was gonna to save us both which in
turn isn't what he really did because he
just went down there and told him that I
came in a minute or two at five o'clock
in the morning you know Richard came
really close to his execution date last
week lawyers filed these documents
before and I want to read to you from
these documents and let you respond to
them is that okay I'm just gonna be a
little bit stop holding cuz they're long
yeah so one of their arguments is you
set mr. gossip up and mr. gossip did not
do anything what do you have to say to
that
for the for the last three months of my
stay there - every time mr. Van tree
showed up did that's what he wanted me
to do he wanted to pay me - to kill him
the interview was conducted inside
prison by Kerry Aspinwall from the
frontier
that's a tulsa-based news website when I
saw it I confess my heart sank a little
because my big regret in covering this
story over the last nine months is that
I never asked Justin's need for an
interview I've been told months ago that
he ignored reporters letters so I didn't
bother writing to him and I pursued
other interviewees it was a mistake
Kerry was more persistent and it paid
off do you believe what he had to say
you know it's hard to tell I don't know
if I was on a jury if I would you know
there's still questions I got the sense
when I've talked to both of them there's
still something I don't know about the
crime Richard's the funny intelligent
kind of guy he can quote Mark Twain I
mean he'd been you know his own best
advocate for a long time now and Snead
is very resolute though so all I can do
is report exactly what he told me Snead
may have stuck to his story that Glossop
was to blame but he added a new detail
one he'd never mentioned in other police
interrogations or in court in any time
that he came around in that room or
whatever he I look back now and noticed
it yeah he went and put some gloves on
and he made sure to his little prince
wasn't there
so he was just guide and misguided youth
as soon as I heard that I thought that's
new is that an attempt to explain why
there was no physical evidence linking
Richard to the murder I asked him about
Snead's claim no Richard owned a pair of
all good no and now he's on TV saying as
we don't Supreme Court he wants that
part of it out as well so he broke it
down for the Supreme Court Gogol Justin
Snead and frontier and you can watch the
whole of the interview and judge for
yourself whether his version of events
is credible Richard's attorney said it
was full of lies and accused Carrie
Aspinwall of asking easy and challenging
questions I know that Don Knight has
criticized where he said where we're
leading softball questions in your
interview and I'll go on record I
publicly I sympathize with that because
when I interview Richard Glossip
you tend to have a very warm
conversation you're not interviewing the
president you're interviewing someone
you've built relationship with who could
stop talking at any time and simply walk
away it's not obliged to talk to you so
I've heard from that point of view but
what's your reaction to what they said
about your interview well not a TV
journalist so I'm not a pro like some
folks and I am the only reason we put it
on video is because we knew the public
wanted to see it and we didn't cut
anything out as you can see and as
they've noted and in there I think you
know as for softball leading questions
well they transcribe several of them
incorrectly so I don't know you can take
that for what it's worth but it was a
follow-up interview it's kind of
important to note as well because I'd
already sat down with him as I mentioned
to you
off-camera because do see would not
allow us to bring one and so to me
that's their opinion they're entitled to
it I'm just asking questions that I
think the general public wants to know I
was talking earlier about the documents
submitted to the court by both sides
when they do so they're made public one
of them submitted by the state turned
out to have something which interested
the defense attorneys it was a report by
a psychologist who interviewed Sneed six
months after the murder it was a
standard procedure to check whether he
was mentally competent to be tried
Edith King Oklahoma counties director of
forensic psychology wrote that Sneed
talked about how it was a murder related
to a burglary Sneed didn't mention being
hired to kill and he didn't mention
Richard Glossip the week before
Richard's new execution date came claims
of witness intimidation by the district
attorney two of the men who'd come
forward to say Sneed boasted of having
framed Richard are former prisoners the
DA David Prater wanted to interview them
about their statements and he wouldn't
take no for an answer one of them
Michael Scott was $200 in arrears for
fines imposed for drink-driving and
marijuana possession a dozen police
officers turned up to arrest him Phil
cross off Fox 25 takes up the story so
they surround the house they call him
and ask him to come out the back door he
comes out the back door and there is a
police officer who has his gun drawn so
he walks out we're in a climate where
Michael Scott says he's heard all about
these issues with police and bad things
happening so he's scared for his life he
says he's scared for his life he's
handcuffed and placed in an
interrogation room where he sees a
according to this court filings he says
he sees a folder marked glossop and stay
written on it and in comes Oklahoma
County District Attorney David Prater
and one of his investigators and they
questioned him about his statement and
and this kid says he's afraid for his
life through all this and doesn't feel
like he has the right to not talk to the
prosecutor this isn't how the criminal
justice system is necessarily supposed
to work Richard Glossop's attorneys
protested to the
of Appeal but the court remains silent
there was no decision on whether
Richards stay of execution would be
extended I was sure that the court would
give its decision one way or the other
on Friday afternoon because I was in
London and six hours ahead of Oklahoma I
spent the entire evening scanning the
courts website and the Twitter feeds of
Oklahoma reporters to kill time I
watched the Justin Sneed interview again
and noticed that the frontier had also
posted another video one of Richard
gossips police interrogations from a
couple of days after the murder back in
1997
I'd read the transcript of the interview
but I'd never seen the video the picture
quality was poor but the sand was
reasonably clear it was upsetting to
hear him talk about how he'd helped
cover up the crime
he told me before about why he did it
blaming bad advice he knows it was wrong
but this was Richard talking about being
an accessory to murder
by midnight it was clear that there
would be no announcement maybe it would
come on Monday but that gave me no
choice I had to fly to Oklahoma on
Monday morning just in case the
execution was still going ahead I kept
hoping it would be a wasted trip I was
flying via dallas-fort Worth Airport and
for most of the flight I listened back
to interviews connected with the case as
the plane descended I switched my phone
and iPad back on so that I'd find out if
there had been a development as soon as
I had a 3G signal as the wheels touched
the runway dozens of emails landed in my
inbox one immediately caught my eye
because of its title it was from a
friend and colleague and simply read I'm
so sorry I scanned the others the Court
had ruled against Richard three to two
essentially the majority of judges
argued that the evidence was hearsay and
it wasn't much different from previous
evidence but the two judges who
dissented issued strongly worded
statements one called blossoms trial
deeply flawed another Clancy Smith said
the tenuous evidence in this case is
questionable at best
while finality of judgment is important
the state has no interest in executing
an actually innocent man I phoned Rich's
friend Kim Van Atta as the plane was
still taxiing to its stand he'd spoken
to Richard had heard the news from a
prison official he hadn't been able to
contact his lawyers Richard is always
upbeat but understandably he was taking
this badly I had to stop using my phone
when I got to immigration the border
control official asked me my business I
said I was a reporter on the way to
Oklahoma he asked why I told him I was
going to see an execution he didn't bat
an eyelid but then I was in Texas the
next call was to sister Helen Prejean
she was in New York for a meeting at the
United Nations it was put in her faith
in the US Supreme Court and another of
Richards attorneys mark olive
he said yes it may be the case that the
Supreme Court takes that could really
undo the death penalty in the United
States and he won just blowing smoke I
quickly drove to the court building to
record an on-camera report for our
bulletin the following morning the Sun
was rapidly going down but I avoided
using it as a metaphor for Richards case
instead I pointed out that his original
appeal against conviction had been
defeated 3-2 to his lethal injection
case at the Supreme Court have been lost
five to four now he had again been
condemned by the narrowest of margins
several judges have agreed with his
arguments but not enough to save his
life two things combined to make it an
even more miserable evening first all
the notes I'd made on my iPad during the
flight had vanished just disappeared I'd
transcribed interviews and written parts
of the script for this podcast for hours
worked vanished in a cyberspace mystery
I tried various methods of retrieval but
to no avail
note to Apple geeks out there
please don't email me with tips or
suggestions it's too late now and yes I
will be more careful with packing up my
work
thank you but more of a problem was that
I hadn't heard from Richard he was due
to call and didn't several of the phone
numbers on his approved list of calls
had been removed from the telephone
system he uses we aren't sure whether it
was deliberate or just a glitch but it
turned out that mine was one of them he
couldn't bring me and so I couldn't ask
him about the news of the courts
rejection Tuesday morning in Oklahoma
and nobody to talk to the attorneys and
sister Helen weren't you to arrive until
late in the evening the district
attorney David Prater refused to talk to
me until after the legal process had
been exhausted he didn't want to preempt
a Supreme Court intervention so taking
some advice from the frontiers reporter
Carrie Aspinwall who's familiar with
searching original court documents I
paid a visit to the basement of the
Oklahoma Judicial Center the building
where the Oklahoma appeal court is based
there's a small room there where you can
ask to view court records a very helpful
Clerk
brought me three cord board boxes the
Richard Glossip case file they'd
obviously been well used one of the
boxes was falling apart inside were
transcripts of police interviews and the
two trials plus crime scene photographs
I found myself looking at color pictures
of the body of Barry Van trees and the
bloodstains in room 102 of the best
budget in I've been covering this case
for a long time now but it was a
sobering moment to see images of the
victim as he was found facedown rather
than the family photo of a smiling Barry
which we've always used in our reports I
also reminded myself the man who did
this who brutally beat Barry to death is
the state's trusted witness whose
testimony put Richard Glossip on death
row there were also videotapes of the
police interviews with both men and
although there was a TV monitor in the
room there was no VHS player I had to
ring up Phil across and ask him if he
could find one in the Fox offices and
bring it down to the courthouse I'd seen
the Snead interview before and we've
used part of it in earlier podcasts but
I also plan Richards first interview
with detectives the day after the murder
throughout he maintains he had nothing
to do with killing Barry Ventre a few
hours later I was talking to Richard
because he couldn't call me on my phone
I met up with Kim Vanessa and spoke on
his what about the US Supreme Court do
you think that you stand much of a
chance they're bearing in mind what
happened the last time over the lethal
injection debate
we'll see what happens on the one it's
court system so I've been doing before
during the call his last meal arrived
yeah what do you got this time Wednesday
morning and a sense of deja vu when I
arrived at the prison but the previous
experience had better prepared me and
certainly slept better and there'd been
an intervention from across the Atlantic
virgin boss Sir Richard Branson had
placed an advert in the local paper in
support of Richard Glossip I emailed his
assistant and within a few hours
he was live on Sky News I believe and
and all our team believed and the
lawyers believe that an innocent man is
in danger of being executed in five
hours time
in the United States of America and and
we're doing everything we can to try to
get the governor of Oklahoma to
intervene to stop the execution and
because I you know personally I think
it's bad enough executing anybody but
executing innocent people is obviously
completely unacceptable how far have you
managed to get as far as Mary Fallon is
concerned we will see in you know three
or four hours time the bizarre situation
in America is that when somebody is
convicted of a murder if they point
their finger at somebody else they can
avoid themselves being executed and
that's what happened in this case
but the Owens for a reprieve weren't
looking good the Supreme Court had
refused to get involved in light before
when Georgia executed a female prisoner
Kelly Gibson Danner the Vatican had
written a letter asking for mercy and
another a papal letter have been sent to
Oklahoma governor mary Fallon sister
Helen Prejean
let me at the prison's main gate ready
to go inside two weeks ago you were very
optimistic how do you feel today
July I'm alive we're alive and the
Supreme Court's alive and they had the
case in their hands I know the lawyers
have done their best in the short period
of time we've had to uncover the new
evidence now I just have to trust that
there will be five Supreme Court
justices who will not only grant cert
but give a stay of execution and Anthony
Kennedy I would suspect would be that
fifth one and all I know is he said
right at the lap of the Pope or right at
the feet of the Pope at Congress the
other day so let's I can only hope
Richard gives me hope because Richard is
poised whatever happens I think Richards
gonna be able to do it and that's that's
everything real quick I'm going to say
very quickly there would you hope that
the intervention from the Vatican to
governor Palin would have any impact
well you never know about the impact but
you know the way God is described as
loving those that deserve it and those
that don't elect you rain fall on the
just and unjust so the reign of the Pope
has fallen in governor Palin's office
and the rest is up there all right and
so into the prison we went and into the
same room as we were held in two weeks
ago once again we were given little
clip-on badges saying execution witness
last time we'd only been in there for
about 15 minutes not enough time to get
the coffee and cookies they promised us
but this time there was no offer of
cookies or indeed anything to eat just
black coffee and bottled water we were
in a large recreation room with an old
pool table pushed into the corner out of
the way to female prison guards who were
friendly but firm kept an eye on us
Kim Van Atta sister Helen and Kim Bell
we're from the huffington post the other
witness crystal Martinez had forgotten
to bring her ID and arrived later
sister Helen went off to the far side of
the large room to pace and to pray we
all chatted amiably for about an hour I
took advantage of a sofa to stretch out
and close my eyes I woke up after about
10 minutes because Kathleen Lord one of
Richard's attorneys arrived
she'd been within between 11:00 and 1:00
and said he was still hopeful things
would turn
there was a clock on the wall so we
could watch the countdown to 3:00 p.m.
when I got to - I didn't feel like
talking anymore and sat by myself or
just walked up and down when I got to
2:30 I began to feel sick not like I was
going to throw up but